356 valuating doesn't opportunities and
150 half ounces you rest of all 356 is a
classes allow students to evaluate not
yet you haven't researched talking about
assess whether either want to develop a
plan and develop a business plan and of
springboard so does as a wide experience
value many many teams in this process so
this is going to go through this is plan
as a very valuable exercise to go
through preparation so yes thank you
Thank You Linda electic I had an
opportunity to look through your
backgrounds and I'd like to get a sense
from the class about how many you plan
to launch a venture in the next year or
two that's great what I'd like to go
through is today is basically how to
structure a plan and you may use the
plan for many purposes but I'd like to
get a sense from the class this is a not
a minor exercise to put together the
plan and what might be some of the
reasons you do that why would you go
through this exercise yes mila
yeah you verify what you're thinking
about so there's a clarify what you're
doing what else might you do the peak
space under the challenge what well yeah
it's some of your challenges what else
yes Gem State validation I mean to
really go through it really ask the hard
questions of yourself if you can't
convince yourself so it validated for
yourself in your your team validate what
are some other some other reasons go
through this you really this is the
first time if you're putting together
the team you're really this one of your
first exercise is to exercise a team
Laura alignment with your yeah yeah and
a big question is should it be asking is
how do you measure success yeah
different meanings for a different so
they're really kind of a three elements
you'll be working with one is a pitch an
oral pitch and then getting a real and
i'll give you slides on all this so you
can just I've got then there's an
oral presentation that is around that
pitch but you'll also need to write a
really 16 to page executive summary and
normally the way it works is you get
some idea of you've got an idea who the
audience is the first thing they'll say
send me an executive summary if you
don't get through the executive summary
you probably don't have the meeting so
you need that and the oral presentation
and then when you're there they you
probably go through your pitch and they
may or may not ask for a final written
plan which really documents a lot of
year the work you've done up to that
point
so we'll see how this works so you
really have to understand really it
define your business understand where
you have gaps you know what are some
real problem areas to gain ownership not
all yourself but other team members and
its your game plan for your launch the
use of this it might be for raising
funds it might be to attract a really
cheap partner it might be gee we really
need this one employee and they'll say
tell me about your business and here's
your plan so you've got various
different youth you might need to
partner with someone gee if we can
really get this one partner outside
that's would be successful so the plan
has to be oriented towards who's the
audience and as you look at your
opportunities here I think you have
various different audiences and this is
really so one class is your investors
but it might be to recruit an executive
team it might be we could really be
successful if we had the following board
members or we could really be successful
if we made this one deal with this one
company that could be our great
distributor so you have to think about
who is your audience and you have a
slightly in a different pitch really
depending upon who your audiences what
I'll focus on more is the investor side
from the for this but just think maybe
the real issue is and I've had cases
I've started on my own background have
actually started successfully seven
companies and I've gone the whole range
from the real issue is i needed raise
capital to another issue i really needed
to attract in these key people and
there's a different kind of pitch across
that those two perspectives
and let's take the investor audience so
the investors could be everyone from
friends and family to angel investors to
some professional investors to maybe
even if you're putting a buyout fund to
a private equity but really
understanding they are they might you
might go in and say I have this great
idea and you look through the background
they just recently lost a bundle on that
or they have a bias against that because
it takes too much capital or they have
no experience in that area so and what
are they really interested in you know
are they really focused on retail or is
it really interested in software are
they interested in cleantech you know
what are their interests what are their
likely concerned so I always read
through the bio we get on the internet
we know the bio talked to people try to
understand them before you send in your
your pitch to them your executive
summary and be very cautious about items
that you might think gee they've lost
money in this area before and you're
coming in for the next time you're
probably wasting everyone's time
Linda here we go yeah all right so let's
think through what elements do you
really really need in this plan the
number one thing is as executive summary
and that really should be a page page
and a half which really summarizes here
is the opportunity this is something
about the size of mark why we're going
to be successful why we have some really
unique value we're adding there who's
the team that's doing this what's the
order of magnitude of the money you're
looking for so you and that should
really be well written carefully done
then from a reviewer what they're going
to look at is the opportunity that in
some detail and the opportunity what
they're going to look at is what's the
market like is this a small market or a
large market what are the trends in the
market what are the underlying trends
that occur in the market do you have a
unique product service offering or is it
just like others product service
offerings in that market what is your
business model and the business model
should be really focus on as much how
you're going to acquire customers and as
we have really you know what's your
unique way of acquiring customers do you
have a unique way to compete against a
competitor from your business model side
and
we met your handouts we're going to have
a after yes it's cribbing and an area
that at least when I look through
business plans as how much research have
they really done have they actually gone
out and showed a prototype with some
customers what are your research results
is it just the internet related or they
actually got out and then tested this in
the marketplace to get some feedback
they have my tender research results
they said here is a prospective customer
that might be willing to buy the product
or service so illustrating you've done
real work from a research side is very
important then so and when ever you get
a sense of the size of the market the
growth trends in the market your product
service offering that's all kind of in
your discussion of the opportunity next
thing is who's going to do the work and
and probably the most important nextdoor
thieve probably equal importance is who
is the team and you know what are the
skill sets you're bringing to what your
experience base why are you passionate
about this activity is this just
something you have an interest and are
you're really passionate about it
because most ventures you're going to be
in it for a period of time and there
will be problems and you really they
know you're passionate about this you
have the right team members or you've
identified you need a team member then
might have for example certain design
skills or might have certain marketing
capability or might have certain
technical skills that you've identified
that and back again how are you going to
market and sell is another area that I
can give so many example is the
competition and I can just give a recent
example in class I had a student team
came to me and first I thought there was
no market and then they came and they
said but there's competition that I said
that's the best news I've seen because
you actually have a market so so make
sure that you've identified who your
competitors are right now who might be
your competitors
and if you don't identify competitors
usually the assumption is you're naive
about the business so you bring forward
the competitive issue not only now but
who might the potential competitors
buddy and then well then you have in the
plan and what I'm going to go back and
do this a little more in detail then you
have in the plan as much about how are
you going to go forward and operate this
from manufacturing operational stage
what are the real issues but the
investor what they're going through
their mind is first is there a real
opportunity here and it says the team
that can deliver and if you miss on one
of those two issues they're probably be
a very polite but short conversation and
then they'll want to look at your
financial projections and and it's
really none of these financial
projections will actually turn out this
way but the idea is what's your
rationale behind that what are your key
assumptions and what you're looking from
an investor side is you're really giving
good thought to this this business is
similar to this business that therefore
we think in a long run it will have
these kind of margins and here's the
rationale for that and as we build out
the sales forecasts here's the real
issue probably the largest degree of
sensitivity in your financials is
predicting revenue you'll probably have
the most swing on basically your revenue
forecast your cost you have so many
people on board you have to buy certain
things you can really get that down but
the revenue forecast is really where
you'll have the largest degree of
uncertainty and then the investment
considerations how much money do you
need now what might you need a year or
two from now what will you accomplish
with that and the mindset you should
have about in the investment area is the
investor is looking at risk and so with
this amount of money we put it in we can
prove that our product works we can
prove that we can get our first customer
with the next amount we can prove our
sales source actually works and we can
prove we can you actually go from this
one customer to several customers with
this next some we can actually ramp the
sales force further and we can prove
that we're profitable so think of this
as a risk reduction area so you're going
through what are the risk you're taking
out so the investor is actually what
they're doing is they're looking at
those risks and how those risks really
interpret back to how much equity they
want to take to take that risk and and
then the your risk and how you mitigate
those so if you look at a plan real
quickly you'll say all right look at the
executive summary I look at the team the
opportunity oh they have nothing about
competition well that's a real issue
they haven't thought about risk their
real issues their financing plan does
not really address how they're really
going to acquire customers then those
that then just start to question the
quality of the team the quality of that
investment so those are just tennis so
what you'll really be preparing in the
future is first this overview executive
summary that try to encapsulate that
then you'll have a slide show which
would probably be 10 15 slides and I
would really recommend if they talk
about Jerry Weissman's book yeah I'd
encourage you to read Jerry Weissman's
book and basically how to give a good
pitch he's got some very very good
techniques and Jerry is actually here in
the valley that youth most CEOs which
are going out to raise for example IPO
go through Jerry's class we bring Jerry
into class I think some of you have seen
Jerry I'd really recommend you Lee it's
got certain techniques adjust how to
present so I'd encourage you to look
through that as you prepare to make your
pitch and then you'll be backing that up
with this written document and there's
you'll probably
in your discussion with your investor
they'll be starting as a set of
questions and I alize find there's
nothing more powerful at the end you say
here it is and we all the questions
advance we have most of them here in
this written plan if you'd like to read
it they might not want to read it but
that what that really shows is you
you've given this thought you've got the
team behind it you really have the
thought behind it you thought about this
in great detail rather than just having
only the slideshow you need the
slideshow to get there you might need
this to close it and may it in there
some cases you might not I invest myself
I won't invest in anything unless
someone's done because I just realize
they've gone through that thought
process so just but others may or may
not well we give it a try here Linda all
right did it alright alright so let's go
back to the executive summary make it
short and compelling and really this is
your this is your real entree and
usually the way that would work is you
might have a colleague or something to
say would you forward this and what
really happens is the ideal way to be
introduced as someone who's actually
been successful with that investor and
they'll say gee Pete I know Pete he's
been with class and i really trust them
and basically and this is a successful
investor and a successful entrepreneur
and they was oh yeah i'd like to have a
meeting would you send the executive
summary and then and and that they'll
read that quickly say then let's have a
meeting let's go forward with the
meeting so its base making sure you have
a wonderful advantage here at Stanford
in that you have a large network take
advantage of that but really look into
the backgrounds of the investors in a
very if I look through your projects
here in the class you have retail you
have someone clean tech you have a whole
spectrum and there's only certain
investors that are really interested in
certain subject areas
be able to explain the business one or
two sentences so they capture them right
up front this is an exciting business
we're into this market we have this
unique product and we've got a team that
can really deliver we've delivered in
the past and here's the kind of returns
you might expect all right good so so
really focus is there a really need or
is this a nice to have them so I mean if
I look through the ventures I've been
involved in those that have just it's
kind of nice to have their really hard
and those that you have a really
compelling need it just drives
everything so it really ask the question
is there a really compelling need for
your product or service and question
that yourself and do feel work on that I
mean one of the best ways to test that
if you have an early prototype and
you're out to a prospective customers if
you can build that for me or you can do
that i'll buy it or and maybe I'll even
help finance that I needed so much and
that then you've got the sense that
there's a compelling need I encourage
you to look for big markets there's as
much work to do work in a small market
as a big market so it's much more
exciting and the other issue is if
you're in a larger market you're
probably morph you'll be in there and
you don't go like this so I'd encourage
you to look at larger markets and small
markets and realize that probably when
you're in there it will change and that
if you're in a larger market opportunity
you'll actually more for change
encourage you also to think about
pricing you know I want price is this a
really valuable service or product and
and you should really have built
yourself a very simple economic model
that you really understand the economics
of this business we always have a series
of student teams when they go through
this exercise and then they get in the
real cost of sale
and that they're not viable so and even
and we can't move the price up more
because there is competitive pressure
make sure that when you present your
forecast on the profitability that you
don't have outrageous I mean it that
your margins have some reasonableness to
it I mean very often from student teams
we have margins and then I asked the
student I don't know of a legal business
that has these margins so you know so
just make sure there's some
reasonableness to it and then why will
you be successful and part of the
reasons you can say I've already been in
this kind of business I've done this
before I have a team I made a lot of
mistakes before in this area and I know
what those mistakes are and I've got
some advisors to help me and and look at
my market research and look at how the
market is taking you off and these are
the trends you know have that compelling
reason because this is a good business
eventually there's a judgment call and
you need to make sure they're convinced
that this there's a real opportunity
here and proof that the team is really i
mean if you've got this incredible team
like that you just I know these team
members I've worked with them there's no
issue we've worked before together or we
bend it we've known each other for a
long period of time we know we can work
effectively that's much more compelling
that I'm alone and I'm think I have to
recruit someone in I'm not sure whether
that'll work and if we do that and a big
one a real big cost in a company is if
you hire someone they don't work out
you're now six months a year two years
later still searching and the risk is
very high please stop me if there's any
questions
I don't we would all right so again back
it wanted just the market size and
growth trends and try to be involved in
areas where there's some really
fundamental change going on I love
fundamental changes for example that
there might be in the internet space all
this social networking that's growing
like that opens up all kinds of
opportunity or it might be in the
International where you might have like
for example we've had student teams look
at opportunities in China you where you
get or demographic changes or there's
some technological change go out those
are really wonderful to ride and that
can be part of the compelling reason you
go to an investor you say these trends
are occurring and I might not be
successful as successful initially but
we're writing the trend and we can morph
and move into a market area that is
really attractive and profitable make
sure you would dress really and this
what the real issue in terms of the
customer issues that you've actually
done field work and you've actually
shown that this is a real interest it
might be something interest to you but
it might not be interest to a large set
of customers that you've done field work
this is real pain point or this is
really add significant value so really
address those issues in terms of all
right
if if there's one thing I look for is
really what is your compelling value
proposition why is this a great offer
and it might be accommodated price and
service and others but why is this
really a wonderful offer to a customer
why is it just kind of a meet to this
you really thought through what the
proposition is to a customer might be an
economic proposition it might be a
social proposition but it's really
compelling it's not just Martin minor we
can go and if you can't answer that go
back and recycle if i look at ventures
i've been involved in and successful
that's it when this when i can answer
this compelling issue then the chance of
success is much less you then always
morphing to you get to the point that
you say this is really really compelling
but i can give numerous examples where
then compelling and where it's been just
marginal and the marginal ones make it
very difficult for you to be successful
wall run again back show your reserved
of market research results if you're
going to an investor in you say we've
been out we've talked to the following
customer or we've had this website up
and we've had 1 million hits on this and
there's interest over here that's very
different than said we think there's
something going on here so i encourage
you really to do significant amount of
market research prototype your products
and make sure you have a sense on that
and you can fail quickly on that you can
go in and look at that's not working we
can do something else and so it really
encourage you to have that and have that
ready when you and feel comfortable
yourself you have to not only feel
comfortable yourself but as a team you
have to feel comfortable so make sure
you have that comfort level yourself yes
no I like to see what I like to see the
market research give various examples
let's a look at these customers we've
been out talking to them here's a letter
that they're willing to buy this if we
can be successful I mean that or but i'd
like to see there's basic market
research you can buy you can see on the
internet those statistics oh that's kind
of the early work the other is actually
actually out testing my product or
service even a prototype I've shown this
to a customer and there's real interests
here's a little video of that you can
call someone up I'd like to see really
touching potential customers if I'm
showing you yeah so what a good ways to
go out and get real yeah go out and show
them and if they tell you it's ugly it's
okay because now you've learned that
you're ugly it's ugly and you can change
and come back and try again and make
sure you maintain relationship with that
person or potential customer and they
say oh yeah and they get more engaged in
that process help tell give me your
honest feedback helps us me a good
product absolutely just you want their
honest feedback but I just had a student
in classes that will I said I know the
president of this one company Oh he'd
really dumped all over it but he told me
this is what we really need I said well
that's wonderful now you know what you
really need
talk about it but I know a school here
they do a lot of they thinking of this
prototype possible be there people are
willing like even if you're starting
literally this paper has wondered are
now or you're taking stuff together with
like you know duct tape as your cheapest
products who will you be back with is
perfect and that looks really beautiful
people yeah that's I mean no we're going
to hear that that design pros really
works and all of a sudden you'll get
someone excited i can describe several
years ago i started a company in the
foreign exchange trading area and we
showed them they said that's not what we
want but we want this and the head
trader said if you can build that will
buy it and it was well that's just the
information we wanted we thought it was
over here but this but we wanted or you
I mean there's always those kind of
cases come about there we go all right
so
so investors betting on you just realize
that's I mean that's the real bad and so
makes because if you're not successful
they're not going to be successful and
they're not only betting on you and your
team members so then Wilson one of the
I'm inai look at the opportunity than
the team and and if the team is right
then you and they're really committed
and need a sense of that commitment and
you need to a part of your business plan
is to flush out the commitment what do
you really measure a success I actually
coached some teams i invest but more as
a coach and i say you got to tell me
what you really believe is successes of
team and what your real weaknesses are
and what we have whom we have to recruit
in to be really successful so so what
roles will they play I mean maybe
there's someone early someone wants the
CEO but maybe someone really feels I
don't want to do that I want to be the
chief technical officer or I my strength
is really in marketing and sales and
that's what I love doing so make sure
you n say in this business we need
absolutely incredible selling capability
so that we can't be successful unless we
really get the star salesman or we can't
be successful unless we have someone
with really good design capability
designing a consumer product so just
really think about that
you're fortunate if you're in this
valley area there's many people that
love to be advisors to companies and
they and they're really they really want
to see you succeed so and they might be
able to bring some very interesting
skill sets there might be in the science
area G we really need some scientists
who really understands this issue will
you can bring them on its advisers and
they'll be very happy to be advisors
this is throwing for them to see you
succeed and it builds strength in terms
of your you're offering to the investor
group really compelling issue is has
this team work together before because
if they work together before one of the
large risk you have from an investor
side is the team looks great on paper
but it's not going to really function
because well they have never worked
together or they don't share common
goals and as I know from my own personal
experience if you lose a key person then
it takes maybe six months nine months a
year before you recapture that skill set
that's very detrimental so make sure as
you get your team together ideally
you've had some experience working
together and maybe that it might be Lisa
putting together the business plan an
ideally that worked in maybe it's
similar capacity maybe you've been to
the GSB together you've worked on but to
try to flush that ideally they've been
in a similar similar company and you've
come together but that is a very and
then make sure you've fought through
leadership and decisions you know who's
going to know who is the leader of the
principal leader because investor wants
to know who is the leader who do I talk
to and maybe the leadership might be
there's a leader overall but there's
really critical skill we have this chief
sales offer there's a VP of Sales is
also really critical and
and we have someone over the technical
side or we have someone is doing design
work or whatever the real needs are of
that company so make sure you fought
that out and have that of during your
presentation you'll be suddenly asked
questions around that and they'll
question you that and they can
understand a good investor can
understand some of the dynamics around
that so you've got the opportunity and
the team all right competition
and there's several exercises there's no
competition today and I can relate
stories from my own experience I thought
there's no other competition and you go
out and one was it was very is in the
computer security software company we
had we thought we had the leading
software we went to a show and out of
Israel came a competitor so that there's
think of known competitors and who might
also compete against you and a good
really you can do as a team is say our
own we've launched our new product or
service now who is going to compete
against us that we're in this business
and how will they destroy us and go
through that drill how will they try to
bankrupt us will they have a lower
priced product and think about that so
when the question comes out you say this
is how we would compete against that
that kind of situation is a good
investor will have that in the back of
demand so we'll have you thought about
so-and-so who's and you might not have
thought about that and how are you going
to compete against them and and then
there's a real advantages you have as a
small company but also just think about
some meiji large company might decide to
get in your area and they can throw
incredible resources against you and how
do you compete against them so just make
sure you have a good section on
competition it increases your
credibility immensely alright so then is
you lay out your plan one way to think
about this is or we're starting up and
we've got maybe we need to build a
little prototype product and maybe we
have to really test this out in the
marketplace and when we've done that
we've shown our product is really value
or service is really valuable and we've
shown real customers will buy it we're
maybe not profitable at that point but
what you've done from an investor side
that's a staging that's an early
state you've proven that out how much
capital do you need to do that now an
investor will feel much more comfortable
I can do that and now at that point now
you'd like to kind of grow the sales
more well we've got one salesman on
board but we need to have more sales
before we need to increase we've got
this working on facebook and we want to
make it work on Twitter also and how do
we get it on both of these and we've got
a little experiment going and we can now
maybe double our sales or triple our
sales and you say now we've proven out
our customer acquisition model and we
need capital to prove that out so you
start to lay this out in stages how much
capital you need initially how much
capital you need to the next stage and
then we need this amount of capital
really get to break-even point at least
from a cash flow side and we can show
some upside so you usually have some
staging of capital and what that implies
is the early capital is going to be more
expensive because you have all these
risks but if you can get that risk out
then the next stage you're a you can get
much better terms so you're really it's
you're basically driving risk out and
improving your terms then think from
this again goes back to who is your
investor now some of you I can see in a
class are going to be involved with
private investors that really just love
Tess flow there's nothing wrong with
that I've been in one investment that we
had 20 years and every month we i got a
check and that's very nice and so it
might not be the one that you can you
know but it's got a very nice cash flow
so think it is the investor really
interested in cash flow is that
important to it and that's probably very
true of some private investors they're
just they participate they really enjoy
they trust you they're going to and
eventually they might own twenty or
thirty percent and that's throws off
cash and they have the fun of working
with you others are going to say that we
have
keep investing over time and our big
gamble is that you can sell this company
to so and so you can sell it to PG or
you can sell it off the Cisco or you can
sell it over here so think you know from
a liquidity side there can be a cash
flow liquidity issue or there can be
liquidity on a potential sale and if
you're not really interested in
providing liquidity to investor then
that's probably not the right investor
would probably be you really have to
think that through so you have to think
from their perspective when do they have
liquidity and some of them don't need
the liquidity immediately they might
want will gamble with you for five years
and then we'll play another say you know
this is a the family foundation we're
expecting to get small amounts of money
each year over time we can invest with
you but there's a different perspective
so liquidity and then think through your
offering and this is really there's two
different perspectives of the
professional investors like to say
here's the terms but I like to have
fought through what terms I'm willing to
accept and which you can think through
is what our perspective returns that
they would get so that opens in some of
the negotiation and you can expect early
investors maybe you want if it's a ten
times their money but later on it might
be three to five times maybe later on
further it might be two times their
money so it you can kind of understand
where they're at and you can say that's
outrageous really you've got it upside
of you're talking about a larger larger
upside here then and then what the
investor will usually always want in
their perspective is they'll say we want
ways to protect ourselves that be and
then this doesn't really turn out as
well as you thought about and usually
that is through a preferred offering
which basically said we get our money
back before you get any money so we're
putting in a million dollars before you
receive any money we get
dollars back and we get some kind of
program share thereafter so expect
they'll probably have those in some kind
of term sheet of that sort and it might
it might also be the other thing they're
probably really concerned about is are
you going to be around if we put our
money in you said well there's a much
more interesting opportunity over here
and I brother and go someplace else so
they'll be terms to really restrain you
from competing against the company
they've already invested it so they will
have want some competition things that
one probably that even though you have
the majority ownership they have there's
some vesting of those shares over time
so they have the right to buy those
shares back if you decide not to
participate going forward so they'll be
in any negotiated agreement there's
going to be turns that try to attempt to
a lease from a financial side protect
the investor and keep alignment of goals
your goals and their goals a lot yes
through the course of the event of
course didn't cross invest yes president
I mean that you have to predict in this
plan discuss how much further money your
they haven't what type of pretty money
evaluation was going on all right well I
think we did way I like to do this you
do that you don't necessarily show them
what you're expected but you have a
sense that G in the long run our company
is going to look like such and such and
it might have and here's a potential
acquisition candidate or it could be
fairly successful as an IPO and here's
probably and this is the reason why it
looks like such and such at that time
yeah up in a while you you you have an
indication and part of that is in the
negotiation they'll come back and we'll
say here's the pre-money and you say
well you know that seems a little
outrageous right and because if you did
that and you look through the arithmetic
you're really earning 50 times your
money and typically you know and you say
I have other and this
I've learned as the norm so it's really
as much for your negotiation but but you
need to show the capital you need
overtime so so if you go into for
example an angel investor maybe their
maximum they would put in a deal might
be a half a million dollars I'm just
saying and you so you need three million
so that'll say I can maybe help you find
a professional investor but on really
early stage and I'll to help you find
that but if they can't help you find you
might be in a difficult situation does
that help you any other questions you
mentioned some there's some asset losses
yeah so I was wondering what kind of
deals expected like are you talking like
a dead now describe the one that I that
I was involved in right so this is a
former GSB and we decided to start up a
business and he was fairly wealthy and
he liked the idea and so he said I'll
fund you and was just was actually set
up as a partnership and it was the S
corporation partnership and he said the
way was structured but we had initially
we paid his money back and once we paid
his money back then we split the pie so
and so going forward the blue tea I just
dividend up but until we do it in it out
and paid his position back none of the
other members and that's not untypical
of that kind of deal so you're basically
dividend out and you structured that
usually at that case some of the issues
he was a wealthy individual so he
structured it so that there was tax
advantageous to him so when we were
getting the company going all the tax
benefits flowed to him and so you can do
some structuring for that side yes
ya know there is the size of maybe
slightly on the place
I like to kind of slightly under play
but in selling to them to but does the
upside is here and then use that as part
of the negotiation for the equity equity
position yeah because and the reality is
most I mean I I've done seven successful
companies not one of them followed the
plan but you know but it was really it
was part of the negotiation there and
you actually find you know you maybe
you're in at six months and you say gee
we have to redirect in a certain way any
any other kind of questions along those
line so yeah so I'd encourage you as you
lay this out try to think of comparables
try to think of the kind of investor
you're looking at and some of them is
them the cash flow is what a lot of the
smaller investors they just look for a
test to generate come and they look it's
fun to work with that person and they
really fun to work with that team like
there's one gentleman we work together
for 20 years he was and it was just we
joined going to board meetings and it
was younger people running the company
it was fine all right so these are the
big risky area really and you'll both
address these in your stage wise
development the market and price do you
have a real market be a real product
what are the risks from that sell an
area that always comes up is how are you
going to acquire customers are you using
the internet to really acquire customers
have you really thought through that how
are you going to prove out that you've
got a really good customer
acquisition bottle so make sure you have
thought that through and what if that
model doesn't work what what
alternatives do you have you this great
product but I can't really get it out to
customers do I have an appropriate
marketing approach have I not got enough
marketing going do I have to spend more
marketing dollars i can relate one time
which I was very frightful about then we
we were we weren't quite getting
traction and the investor said let's
start throwing 2 million a month in
marketing dollars and I'm looking at
this is crazy but they said well back
you because we believe you've got an a
market research to prove that they were
right but I was very very frightened I
mean just seeing this sum of money being
placed each money for ads and going out
to try to get the market awareness so
there's so really think about the
marketing area from a technical side try
to ask the this kind of question really
look at what we're the real technical
risk is not whether you can build it but
what really has to be what really has to
go right and sometimes you look through
a pride there's just as one thing if we
can really get this one piece right then
the other pieces are doable but we have
to really address that technical risk
first and this happened very often as
science time related activity or it
might be a regulatory thing we have to
get through the government FDA test and
if we get through that world k or if
this bit of science really works we've
got a home run now and we have to get
patents on that earth but one caution is
as you work with the technical team they
might want to work on all aspects and
you have to focus on what the real
technical risk are so focus on where the
technicals
so you'll have and I'd like to see a
section in your report saying here are
some of the risk and this is if this
goes wrong this is how we think we can
mitigate that risk so that or there
might be an issue for example we're out
there in the marketplace and we're
fairly disruptive in the marketplace and
a major competitor might come in and
here we here is how we the way we might
not be able to compete but they might
see we're ahead of the market by two
years and no bias and here's and the
reason was the way we're going to
mitigate that we're going to have on our
board of directors someone from what we
think might be one of the competitive
companies and they'll let us know and we
make a deal so you just think about
other kind of risks or one of the
scarier risks is sometimes government
risk you know what can happen is there
might be a regulatory change and we're
really betting on this and that happens
then what we do so just think about
place the investors situation you know
what could go wrong and how and what
they're looking for you is as much your
fought and you're thinking about the
risk elements and if you thought about
that and if I look through a planet I
don't see it a direction on looking at
risk then I know competitive analysis no
risk analysis and some fancy financial
numbers it's kind of you lose some
confidence so back to your plan so
you're going to have a basic a really
nice executive summary to get them in
cloud and then probably 10 to 15 slides
that tell the story and what the story
is going to be as much as about you
they're going to add so you don't have
as a lot of details on the slides they
really want to see you so the real issue
is you
and what's have it then your written
plan really clearly did make sure you
clearly define your business this is our
business this is what we're offering
this is why we believe we can be
successful back on the opportunity make
sure you define the opportunity and and
and as I've mentioned before I just so
convinced on the value proposition if
you have a compelling that value
proposition a great team and a good
market you'll be successful so
acknowledge the competition and identify
what can go wrong and then be prepared
to negotiate gee you're going to invest
a half a million dollars here your own
twenty-five percent of us here's the
upside and maybe in five years from now
that half a million if might be where
seminary times or eight times that but
we quit actually if we were really
successful it could be worth 25 times
but our base case at five times and and
they'll say and not only that we have a
product extension that we could really
we're in the US market but we could also
enter the European markets or the Asian
markets and I could double or triple a
so now you've created a reasonable case
and then some potential rent romance on
the upside and make sure it's clear and
readable and not a lot of jargon assume
that the vocabulary level if you're
there is a lot of jargon in there just
make it really clear and easy to read so
and you're again your basic pitch maybe
10 or 15 slides be prepared to present
for maybe 20 to 25 minutes and then
you'll be two and eight for another 20
to 25 minutes and then a nice clear
written plan which takes work I mean
it's the and then as a team you'll have
to go through that several times to get
a really clean business plan B
no no usually what will happen you'll
get in you'll start you'll be in about
two minutes and they'll say but tell me
about the market I didn't I remember
seeing a competitor over there tell me
about that and then say oh you claim you
have this background tell me about your
background more and the lot is too you
won't probably work your way through
your slides but you might say well I'd
like to talk about this and then you've
got the backup information or of them i
would like to show you this market
research we've done and you say look at
this is a letter we have from a
potential customer that wants to buy our
product and those and they'll probably
be that kind of dialogue if the most
likely and part of this they'll look is
your ability to manage is in a potential
leader give you can manage that that
conversation and bring them back to
where you'd like to drive it i have some
so those are a winning plan and now i
have some information which we can hand
up further which basically if you detail
the hand on and you need to look at this
is details in your written plan and
realize this is not every plan is
different so these are kind of
components and you might emphasize one
component more than another for example
there might be issues related to sales
and marketing might be really critical
the economics but these are broad issues
that we have is an outline maybe we can
hand those out i'll be glad to entertain
any questions yes
yeah you know it's how it described very
early in my career and later on so you
might say TI if you know someone that I
versus how do you are introduced to the
person so the introduction is going to
be really important and then you an
astute board member will say like to
meet with you and go through your
presentation and you have to say well
this is really a wonderful opportunity
over this area I think you could add
real value because I know your
background it might be to say you're a
scientific advisor you're really I've
read about your background you really
know the chemistry in this area and you
could be an incredible advisor would you
like to be on board and then they'll and
they'll say well I might have a conflict
of interest or they might not have a
conflict of interest and they say that's
and I know you live well and or I've
known of you and you there's and I'll
probably immediately do some reference
checking on you because a significant
board member of what their big issue is
also the reputation so that what they're
adding is their reputation and they'll
say can you give me some personal
references and so they'd probably say
you'd probably say well yes you can call
someone so and so and so so they do that
and then the next possibly negotiate
they say well we'd like what are you
offering in terms of ownership and it
depends on how large the pie is you know
what the ownership the typically is and
then you'd say say well what are what
are my responsibilities as a board
member and then they say well we'd like
you to be a board member or maybe we
just want you to be a scientific advisor
as a board member you now have I now
have responsibility for other
shareholders of a scientific advisor I'm
just really responsible for bringing in
some expert knowledge to you so you
think about the role and what role they
could really play and a good board
member will say well I've kind of
conflict over here or I really can't
commit the time and I want you to be
successful but I can't or I can't come
at the time it sounds exciting
does that help a little yeah any other
questions yes one of the things we're
trying to do market research and really
gauge viability is that the folks who
would be most helpful to talk to you we
think could actually be companies that
down the road would either want to
acquire us or consider as competitors so
what sort of considerations that we have
really early there we are for the sake
of also validating our well let's say
the potential acquirer that's not all
bad yeah i mean i can relate i've done a
fair amount ins in the computer security
area and early-stage i would try to get
meetings with mcafee and others and and
if they meet with them we'd have kind of
a discussion what we were doing but we
wouldn't say our proprietary algorithm
but we'd get feedback from them and then
I knew that if they were really
interested and they were in that space
and we got to a certain scale might be
an acquirer so that's not all bad and
plus you're already getting back some
competitive information they say well we
really don't want to talk to you because
we're we've got an nd a nondisclosure
agreement and this would be we just
don't want to be in that that situation
well that is giving you some very good
competitive information that the
competitors there bring smaller
organizations realize the biggest
challenge is in execution and so if
you've got that it's the idea has value
but the real value is an executing so if
you've got an incredible team that can
execute well you probably will win so I
know people are always cautious about
that and if you and I find the least my
experience most people are ethical and
you go and i'll say i don't want to talk
to you because we're doing work in that
area and we
they don't want to do that or if you
have something proprietary and they were
sharing proprietary then usually sign
some mutual NDA yep and investors
equality investors will at least my
experience event equality investor will
probably invest in your firm but not in
a competitive firm because they've got
to they've also got a reputation and if
their reputation is they don't act with
integrity this is a very least i know
this valley this is a very small valley
and you would not be that would not help
them at all plus but i think it's just
more of a personal integrity yeah yes
yes I'm Jason so I need going back to
the board member question yeah the
opportunity yep but they possibly saves
the 50 million dollar grant attorney
what would you expect in 50 million
final valuation is so I mean it depends
on a little bit let's give give you
something to give you some counter bit
let's say you're a medical doctor and
you really this is a small potential
drug into a small market but you're
really passionate about this this
outcome this might help someone in
Nigeria it might be a specialized drug
they build their probably less motivated
on the ownership side is more this is
really exciting and and I you know
there's something I'm passionate about
so I think you want to look for the
passion on the person that and if it's
so if it's it's really is this something
really interesting to them and it's got
to have some merit to them in a long run
but I think that's the lower interest if
I looked when I was a younger man in
starting tonight two people and they
really were excited about what I was
doing and so we
gave him a couple percent here and there
and but they actually coached me and it
was really the and I feel very grateful
to them so it's really that kind of
relationship you know are they getting
rewards other than just monetary if it's
a 500 million dollar thing the
negotiation will be different because
then they'll probably want slightly more
and it's also their reputation at stake
is there she a reputation of that state
and will they like to go out and say
what I'm involved in Jason's company and
they're doing this exciting area it's
not and they're really adding some
significant value and they can talk to
their friends about and why do some like
I'm a trustee and iron you know nothing
about that but I'm excited what's going
on there and I can realize I can through
my background I can add significant
value so there you know the upside is i
donate so I mean so there's a really so
look for someone who is motivated and
interested in your opportunity and
believes they can add value
we have enough time to revive a break
and one lap around the building we're
gonna start again 350 Michael game is
going to be here I did my reading